hey 42 here this is hornsy project 1
a wind farm currently under construction
off the coast of yorkshire
when it is completed in 2020 it will be
the largest wind farm
in the world it will power 1 million
homes
but this project will collectively cost
consumers in the uk an additional 4.2
billion pounds on their energy bills
that's fine i guess if it's going to
save the planet
but is it really it turns out that
renewable energy
isn't as rosy as we have all been
sold 97 of scientists believe that
climate change is real
and it's an issue we need to face today
it's estimated that the effects of
climate change
will kill at least 150 million people
this century all of these premature
deaths could be avoided if the average
global temperature
could just be reduced by 1.5 degrees
celsius
professional hippies spend their lives
doing two things
dying their hair and getting angry at
governments for their apparent
lack of action on climate change there
are a very small number of countries
however
that have heard the message loud and
clear and are leading the way on fixing
the planet's thermosap by investing
billions into renewable energy the most
prominent
is germany today between 40 to 50
percent of germany's energy comes from
renewables
such as wind solar and hydro
germany then is making an exemplary move
in the right direction
aren't they well let's take a closer
look at germany's most popular renewable
choice
wind power wind turbines are fantastic
for reducing co2 emissions
we all know that building wind turbines
on the other hand does actually produce
a huge amount of co2
to smelt and manufacture the humongous
steel bodies and aluminium blades
but once it's up and running a wind
turbine pays off its co2 debt
within five months so it's not really an
issue
no the issue is that a low carbon
footprint
is just about the only benefit of winds
turbines
they kill endangered species of birds
quicker than the duke of wellington on
new year's day
hundreds of thousands of birds are
killed by winds turbines
every year and thousands of those are
rare species of large birds like eagles
over a million bats are also killed each
year by wind turbine blades
and solar has its own unique issues
mainly toxic waste
well-made solar panels have a lifespan
of 20 to 25 years
but with their huge and growing
popularity cheaply made
chinese solar panels are flooding global
markets
these can break down in as little as
five years
and many of them contain highly toxic
chemicals that are harmful to human
health
and can cause cancer such as lead
cadmium
and chromium unlike nuclear waste the
toxicity of these elements never decays
all solar panels can break and do so
with varying degrees of regularity
when the glass is smashed toxic
chemicals can leach into the soil
and thus public water supplies also we
have no plan to dispose of these
mountains of
broken solar panels safely the vast
majority of solar
panels will be shipped after countries
that have no safe way
of dealing with their toxicity countries
where we already send
millions of tons of our tech waste each
year
such as africa and other developing
regions
these are teeving issues that will
hopefully be fixed by better
decommissioning protocols
and pipelines and improved solar
technology
both solar and wind however have an
inescapable issue
that no amount of technology can fix
they only produce energy when the wind
blows
or the sun shines in some locations
that's as little as 10 percent of the
time and yes we've built wind farms in
those locations
even the most efficient wind and solar
farms only work optimally
30 of the time although to be clear most
solar and wind farms produce
some amount of energy around 75 percent
of the time even if it is just a little
this means we will always need a more
consistent energy source
such as fossil or nuclear to cover
renewables down times
perhaps in the future battery technology
will reach a point where
it becomes feasible to store copious
amounts of excess power from renewable
sources
and then the grid can be fed off those
whilst the wind isn't blowing and the
sun isn't shining
but currently the technology isn't even
close
as it stands no battery array in the
world can hold even
a fraction of the power needed to
sustain a city
for more than a few minutes the current
largest array built by tesla in
australia
is a 100 megawatt array that can sustain
30 000 homes for an hour
in fact without having huge and
expensive battery arrays
dotted around every country which would
be an eyesore
solar and wind have seemingly
insurmountable
redundancy issues fossil and nuclear
power plants both work within a similar
framework
the fuel produces heat which is used to
create steam
which turns a large turbine which turns
a generator
which creates electricity and when i say
large turbine i mean stupidly large
these goliaths usually weigh in at over
100 tons of solid steel
its immense mass has some benefits
primarily
redundancy nuclear power plants produce
energy
24 7 365 days of the year
they are only shut down once every two
years to refuel
but what if it has to shut down in an
emergency
what if it fails and stops producing
steam to turn the turbine
actually what if every single fossil
fuel and nuclear power plant in the
country
all shut down at the same time for some
reason
the power would go out right well
not quite you see because of the immense
inertial mass of a spinning turbine
there is enough centrifugal force to
maintain its rotation
and continue to generate power as normal
for a couple of minutes
without any steam input this gives the
national grid a small
yet crucial time to restart the power
plant and get it back online
because of this crucial redundancy
window unplanned power outages due to
hiccups at power plants
are extremely rare most power cuts
happen due to weather affecting other
parts of the infrastructure
such as overhead cables wind turbines
don't have a large
turbine to rely on if it fails it just
stops producing power instantaneously
so does a solar farm although there is
currently hype surrounding new
hybrid wind turbines that have a backup
battery in the base of the tower
which will help overcome this issue
somewhat but then there's an issue of
land usage
and the environment to build these huge
arrays of wind turbines and solar panels
an area of over 5 000 square meters
usually has to be cleared of all
vegetation
and wildlife this is disastrous for the
ecosystem the local environment
and the poor various species that may
call it home
to power a country such as the united
kingdom using exclusively wind and solar
power
it is estimated that up to 25 of the
country's land surface
would have to be cleared and transformed
into wind or solar farms
wind farms only return 2.5 watts per
square
meter compare that to nuclear which
produces 1 000
watts per square meter and it's clear
how inefficient renewables are when it
comes to land usage
we could mitigate some of this
disastrous loss of nature by
building all of these wind farms
offshore although we still don't fully
understand the long-term effects of
offshore wind farms on marine
species but this isn't actually the plan
sure we're building offshore wind farms
but the uk currently has 271 farms
planned
over the next decade about half of them
are currently under construction
but only 25 of these will be offshore
although it's worth considering that the
offshore arrays do tend to be far larger
than their land counterparts
there's an important philosophical
question to be answered here though
by destroying huge sways of nature to
build renewables
aren't we destroying the very natural
world
that renewables are intended to save
but what about the cost of human life
caused by direct accidents such as
reactor meltdowns
surely this is one area in which
renewables can win hands down
well the figures may shock you as they
shocked
me the most dangerous are as to be
expected the fossil fuels
coal tops the figures with a hundred
thousand deaths per petawatt
hour then oil at 36 000 then biomass
with 24 000 deaths
natural gas at 4000 and that's not
factoring in the millions of deaths each
year as a result of the air pollution
from all of these sources
but it's the carbon neutral energy
sources that have the most
interesting figures hydro 1400
also hydro secretly produces quite a
large amount of co2
solar 440 deaths and wind 150
although there are no completely
reliable data sources for wind turbine
deaths
more data is needed here it's what's at
the very bottom of the list
however that may shock you nuclear
is just 90 deaths per petawatt hour
and that includes chernobyl fukushima
and three mile island
nuclear energy has a really bad public
image
it's no surprise with its association
with nuclear warheads and chernobyl
but you can't ignore statistics and it
is statistically the safest form of
reliable power production we
have today nuclear energy and negative
press go together like greenpeace
and propaganda and so there are many
countries that have been decommissioning
nuclear reactors
in favor of renewable sources but in an
ironic twist of fate
nuclear may just be the energy source
that could save our planet
nuclear fission is big and scary but it
has so many
benefits that cannot simply be ignored
nuclear power plants produce
zero carbon emissions their only
byproduct
is nuclear waste but unlike byproducts
of all the other forms of energy
production
this is 100 contained and doesn't leak
out into the environment
nuclear waste can also be recycled and
reused in reactors multiple times
it's important to note however that the
uranium mining and enrichment processes
do use fossil fuels and this does
produce a lot of co2
but when we average it out over a power
plant's life cycle
a single nuclear reactor and all its
related industries
produces a median of 65 grams of co2
per kilowatt hour that's roughly the
same amount of co2 produced by wind
farms
over their life cycle taking their
manufacturing and regular maintenance
into consideration as well
but nuclear's carbon footprint could be
even lower
than wind allow me to expand since 1987
russia and the us have been mutually
decommissioning their nuclear warheads
even if recent political hiccups have
put a spanner in the process
every year old nuclear warheads are
still regularly retired
and decommissioned this creates a steady
influx
of already highly enriched uranium fuel
that can be used in nuclear power plants
to create energy
completely bypassing the uranium mining
and enrichment processes
and thus bypassing co2 emissions
altogether
skeptics believe that nuclear power
plants lead to nuclear weapon
proliferation but in fact it's the
complete
opposite the absolute best way to reduce
the number of nuclear weapons in the
world
is by building more nuclear reactors
in 2013 19 of the world's nuclear energy
needs were fueled by uranium 235
from decommissioned nuclear weapons
let's take a look at two real live
countries that have taken
completely opposite paths when it comes
to energy
germany has invested heavily into
renewables and has decommissioned
17 of their nuclear reactors and
merkel's government pledged to remove
all of their nuclear reactors by 2022
so today only six percent of germany's
power comes from nuclear
at the opposite end of the scale france
has
invested heavily in nuclear as its
primary source of power
they currently have 58 active reactors
and more than 80 percent
of france's energy needs are met by
nuclear by far the highest per capita
in the world the result germany's co2
emissions per capita are double that of
france
and french households enjoy a much lower
energy cost as well
they pay only 0.1799 euro per kilowatt
hour
germans pay almost double that for their
electricity
0.3 euro per kilowatt hour
the second highest in europe notably
germany's energy costs have increased by
50 percent
since starting their big push towards
renewables
i'm not trying to actively disparage
renewables i think they have an
important part to play
in saving the planet but i believe it
should be a far
smaller part than what we are currently
aiming for it for no other reason
than to not see our world's beautiful
landscapes littered with gigantic
obnoxious windmills
not if there is no overwhelming benefit
over the alternative
humanities cleanest cheapest form of
energy
has been right in front of us since the
40s
and until nuclear fusion comes along we
should be investing more in nuclear
fission
to prevent greenhouse gases without
needing to destroy
thousands of square miles of our
beautiful planet to litter it
with bird blenders but what if nuclear
energy
could be improved even further what if
it could produce
little to no waste and be completely
safe and meltdown proof
well maybe it can in 1950 indian
physicist homi babha
postulated that perhaps another fuel
from the typical uranium-235
and plutonium-239 could be used
for nuclear fission thorium
thorium is a naturally occurring
radioactive metal
that is four times as abundant on earth
as uranium
after world war ii a reactor design that
used thorium as its fuel
a molten salt reactor was created by the
us government
and the first experimental reactor of
its kind was built
at oak ridge national laboratory and it
successfully generated electricity
between 1965 and 1969
but the u.s government decided that the
future of nuclear energy
was in uranium not foreign and so pretty
much every reactor in the world since
the 60s has used uranium fuel
there were many reasons for uranium
being chosen as the
de facto fission fuel over thorium
but one of the most prominent was that
uranium makes much
better bombs uranium enrichment plants
produce highly enriched
uranium that can either be used in
nuclear warheads
or to power people's homes thorium on
the other hand
can be used to make nuclear weapons but
it's a lot more difficult
and more inefficient but that's not the
only benefit
of thorium based power over uranium
thorium reactors produce
much less nuclear waste one chinese
scientist claims
that there will be a thousand times less
nuclear waste from thorium reactors
also since natural thorium can be used
directly as a fuel
it does not need to be enriched and it
gets better
another thorium reactor design known as
liquid fluoride thorium reactor or
lifter has a unique design that its
proponents claim
is meltdown proof you see the most
common cause of reactor meltdowns in
current uranium plants
is excessively high and runaway
temperatures
usually due to power failures which can
lead to insufficient cooling
but lifters contain a plug at the bottom
of the reactor
that is designed to melt if the
temperature gets too
high this causes all the fuel to drain
into an underground
safe storage tank which in theory
should completely avert a catastrophic
meltdown
it all seems too good to be true and
science writer richard martin certainly
thinks so he writes
thorium could provide a clean and
effectively limitless
source of power while allaying all
public concern
weapons proliferation radioactive
pollution toxic waste
and fuel that is both costly and
complicated to process
but like everything in life thorium
isn't short of its detractors
there are some who argue that because
thorium is still
highly experimental and it hasn't been
operational on a large scale like
uranium reactors have
it can't yet be trusted and it may not
be all it's been made out to be
but i guess the only way we can find out
for certain whether thorium is the
golden
goose of clean energy is by putting it
into use
and that's exactly what india is doing
right
now india has one of the largest natural
suppliers of thorium
and they have pledged to meet 30 of
their energy demands with
thorium reactors by 2050. britain france
canada america china and the few others
are currently looking into thorium as a
potential energy source
but india is currently the only country
that has a well-thought-out
government-approved and funded plan to
ramp up thorium-based energy production
india plans to have over 60 functional
thorium reactors by 2025
and since india is the world's third
largest polluter
it seems like a necessary step that
could help preserve the planet
for a little while longer but it's going
to require action from more than just
one country to save our planet
to be completely honest the world needs
to look towards china to stop
burning dinosaurs for fun just under 30
percent of the world's carbon emissions
come from china
it's not surprising since the staggering
55 percent of power production in china
is coal based a tiny four percent of
china's power comes from nuclear
as of 2018. i'm not saying we should
abandon all forms of energy except
nuclear wind and solar renewables have a
huge
and beneficial part to play in saving
the planet
but all nations should be looking to
eradicating coal-based energy production
it's horrendously inefficient you have
to burn a load of coal and release a ton
of co2
for a pathetic return of energy it kills
millions of people each year from
pollution
and it's quickly killing the planet too
but perhaps as most developed nations
are looking to replace coal power
nuclear shouldn't simply be swept aside
for renewables
renewables may be the fashionable and
popular option
but that doesn't necessarily make it the
better option
thanks for watching i've recently
launched my first book which i'm
crowdfunding
sticker flag in it a thousand years of
bizarre history from britain
and beyond if you want to get your hands
on a first
edition signed copy then head on over to
unbound the links in the video
description
check out the launch video over there if
you haven't already and pledge today
thank you